let's go to Adam from North Carolina
Adam please please welcome to the
program
thank you for having me David last time
I called in was about bumper stickers a
long time ago please uh what great to
have you here
I I have to say Ron DeSantis I'm not a
fan of him yeah but he's going to
steamroll Trump and if it's Biden he's
going to steamroll Biden you think huh
what what uh what evidence do you have
to suggest that
well I really I wasn't so much into Iran
I don't like him but then I started
looking into him and I was like this guy
went to Harvard he went to Yale he went
to Naval Justice school he's got a
really strong background that's going to
be like on paper he looks good well one
of the funny things about that is
sometimes going to Harvard is good if
you're a Republican and sometimes it's
proof that you're some kind of woke
leftist it's very funny the Harvard
thing whether they like people who went
to Harvard or didn't it kind of depends
whether they're left or right wing but
you're getting to something that I've
said before which is I think Ron
DeSantis pretends to be much dumber than
he actually is
yes I truly believe he he's the 4D chess
player Trump the Trump's the guy who
pretends to play 14 tests the part I do
hesitate on with desantises I don't re
he's so uncharismatic and I don't know
that you can you know he can dumb
himself down to appeal to Florida voters
from his Harvard Education but it's hard
to create Charisma where there is none
and on a national campaign I just don't
know what that would be like we're gonna
have to wait and see
I agree it's going to be interesting and
I'm sure everything's going to be
revving up here soon thank you for
taking my call if you did my pleasure
thank you so much for calling in thanks
to everyone who called in we're going to
take a break and we will take calls
again in 2022. 2023 is not here yet and
the phone calls will continue quick
break be right back